wanted people to to have food so
we made a break a 10 minute longer and
but eager with the talk 45 minutes and
then we moved the next stop also
so the next talk is given by Igor
Oliveira about improvability of strong
complexity and lower bounds in bounded
arithmetics so we continue
which is perspective and
this yours thank you so uh yeah I'm glad
to be giving this talk
so I was here time was a few years ago
and I think I had just finished writing
a pic with Craig check on improvability
of upper bounds
and I explained the paper to a famous
complexity theorist I think for about an
hour
and after I explained the proof and
everything
and then he told me oh so you're showing
on probability of upper bounds oh but I
care about unperfability of lower bounds
so
yeah so maybe I did a pretty bad job
that day and explained the result but uh
yeah today is gonna be about
improvability of lower bounds so it's uh
I think these are both a very
interesting directions but we're
Switching gears from the previous call
okay and this is a joint work with giato
Lee who is a student at singwa and Jato
visited Warwick last year that's when we
started working on this and he did a
really fantastic job in this project
um
okay so we know that the goals of
complexity Theory uh the main goals are
like separating complexity classes and
proving Circle lower bounds
and even the most optimistic complexity
fear would agree that we seem to be very
far from showing this uh lower bounds
and resolving these main open problems
and for that reason over the uh previous
decades many researchers have
investigated barriers to showing such
lower bounds
but unfortunately these barriers they
tend to be formulated and very specific
in ad hoc way and they are limited in
scope
so for instance if you're familiar with
the natural proofs barrier and with
harness magnification
it's not too hard to see that by using
like simple reductions you can sort of
avoid the framework of natural groups
so these barriers they are very useful
but they are also Limited in many ways
and this leads to the following question
so perhaps we simply haven't been clever
enough to design this uh lower bound
technique that will allow us to solve
the main open problems
but at the same time that could be a
deeper and more fundamental reason for
why it's hard to show lower bounds
and in particular uh there is this
intriguing possibility that maybe very
strong complex to lower bounds they are
improvable in the usual Fields where we
can formalize algorithms in complexity
uh so I don't have a good intuition for
whether this is the case if like the
main open problems would be improvable
or independent but I think it's an
intriguing possibility that that
requires uh more investigation
so this motivates the development uh
more principled approach uh
trying to understand difficulty of
analyzing computations and showing lower
bounds
and we do it in this project from the
perspective of mathematical logic
uh so here's a brief summary of the
result so ideally you would like to fix
a theory that is able to formalize all
known results in algorithms and
complexity and to show in this Theory I
can show a lower bound
so it's not entirely clear which theory
is this or and we also don't have a
result as strong as this one but we can
at least hope to fix a few that can
formalize many of the interesting
results in the field
uh so for example uh there's this field
called APC one that can prove many uh
Advanced results like the PCB theorem
Circle lower bounds and so on
and in this project we are able to show
uh some profitability result for APC one
and indeed for much stronger theories so
here's a calorie of the main result uh
we proved that this Fury APC one
cannot show a strong lower bound
separating the third level of the
polynomial hierarchy
so in other words we're looking at
separations between for our exists for
our versus exists follow exist
computations and uh I'll explain later
what I mean by strong but there is a
sense in which this Theory can't really
understand these two computations okay
it can show lower bounds separating
these two classes of computations
and uh this is an unconditional result
and um in order to prove this theorem uh
we also introduced a simplified a
convenient game theoretic witnessing
result that allows us to obtain
computational information from proofs of
sentences of very high quantifier
complexity
and uh maybe the formulation that we
have in this paper will be useful in
other application
I probably won't have time to talk about
this witnessing result in this talk but
to have a look at the paper uh in case
you're interested
okay so here's the plan so I'll give a
very brief overview of bounded the
arithmetic uh and talk about the
previous work and then uh we'll move on
to discuss the results
probably most of you already know so
bounded arithmetic these are class of
theories uh the capture proves the
manipulate concepts of bounded
complexity
so for instance maybe you can consider
the proof that there are infinitely many
Primes
and one of the most well-known proofs
will say let's look at let's assume by
contradiction that we only have finitely
many primes we're going to take the
product that our previous primes plus
one and from there we're going to do
something else
so if you're trying to formalize this is
a fear of bounded arithmetics so this
sphere will have to understand
how do I talk about the product of all
primes up to a given length and can I
prove the basic properties of this
object that it just defined and so on
okay so this introduced some challenges
um and there are many different theories
of bounded arithmetic some notable
examples are pv1 uh the formalizes
polynomial time reasoning we also have
buses hierarchy where we can manipulate
Concepts that we can Define in the
levels of the polynomial hierarchy and
more recently you have Xperia AP1 that
allows us to formalize uh some
probabilistic arguments
and the sphere is they have been
explored for many years and there are
like hundreds of papers around the
arithmetic and textbooks uh I won't I
have time to cover a bonded arithmetic
in detail in this talk but I will at
least uh
describe the formalization and the basic
properties we need from vulnerability
okay so this fear is we're going to be
talking about the first order setting
here the intended model is the set of
natural numbers so this is the domain of
the the structure and we interpret the
function symbols uh and the relations uh
uh with respect to the natural numbers
okay so that's the intended model of the
theory
and to talk about polynomial time
reasoning and extensions we need to be
able to talk about polynomial time
functions in the theory
now
it will be difficult to do that if we
had to talk about Turing machines and so
on
but fortunately there's a way to capture
polynomial time computation in the
machine independent way as mentioned by
Albert uh and and this is copern's
characterization of polynomial time
uh just to be clear uh while we talk
about numbers we can consider some
efficient bijection between natural
numbers and strings
so whenever I talk about polynomial time
computations you can think about Turing
machines manipulating strings and
there's a bijection between strings and
numbers
Okay so
for FP uh by core terms result is going
to be equivalent to the set of functions
that you can obtain from a few base
functions
these are the base functions here and
applying composition and an operation
called limited recursion on binary
notation to the functions that you have
already constructed
so for this talk you won't need to
understand this theorem I just uh
showing it to you so I get a sense of
how you can talk about polynomial time
computations in the field
so there's a limited recursional
notation will allow you to starting from
a few functions Define a new one it's
called f by having like a base case and
the two uh induction case of recursions
and you also need to satisfy some bounds
that keeps your computation problem on
your time
so yeah don't worry if you uh haven't
seen this before it's just a a very nice
way of capturing polynomial time without
talking about machines
and the unprovability result we consider
uh the language or the vocabulary of the
theory
will have the constant simple zero and
one
and it's going to have a function symbol
for every algorithm for every polynomial
time computation that you can introduce
using hope Homes Construction
okay and we also have predicate symbols
or equality and less than equal
so we have a function symbol for every
algorithm
and the theory also understand how
different algorithms are built from each
other
is a clear definition of the language
the constants function symbols and the
predicating
all right
okay so now the fear is we consider uh
we call them tipv so picks an integer I
and tipv is going to be the theory of
how true for out Sigma b i minus 1
sentence is in this language lpv that I
have just defined
so true sentences means uh the uh the
sentences that are true in the natural
numbers
now let me tell you what is this class
of sentences for all Sigma b i minus one
I equals one uh
this is going to be just for all
sentences so this will be the universal
sentences the ones that do not use
existential Quantified
okay so everything that you can write
just Universal quantifiers and that is
true is going to be an axiom of T1 TV
so when I is larger than one
for instance when I equals 3 then t3pv
will contain as axioms out through for
our Sigma B2 sentences
so now these are the sentences where you
have uh Universal quantifiers without
bounds
and then you have uh two blocks of
quantifiers starting from existential
and then you have a forau and now this
are bounded quantifiers
okay so that means that whenever you uh
quantify or a variable it has to be
bounded by the term of the previous
variables appearing in the sentence
Okay so brows Sigma B2 will have two
blocks of boundary 25 yes after a
universal 25.
then you have like this quantifier three
formula
that generalizes to every fits at that
so let's see some concrete examples
so firmative theorem so it says that for
every a and for every P so this will be
your universal quantifiers default
bounds
if a to the p is not congruent to a
module P then there exists uh an integer
D that is non-trivial and that divides p
so as you can see here you have a bound
on this existential quantifier it's at
most a variable that appeared before
so this is what I mean by a bounded
quantifier
and if you check the like you formalize
this and look at the quantifier complex
of the sentence it's going to be like a
Pharrell Sigma be one sentence
because that is the four hour for A and
P and then there's an existential
boundary 25
th and uh because it's a four housing
would be one sentence it's going to be
an axiom of p2pv because it is a theorem
that is provable in t2b
the second example the Dual with Pinter
principle
so we fix our function symbol F in the
language of the field so a polynomial
time function
now it says that if you map two to the
end pigeons to a slightly larger number
of holes then there's an empty hole
and you can also formalize this uh using
the language of the fuse and
you're gonna have like a four out on the
Fire
and for our this is just some parameter
C forget about it and then there exists
this bounded y such that for every X
which is also bounded
f of x is different from y
Okay and like Albert was explaining
before uh you can talk about lengths of
integers and that's a convenient way to
express that 2 to the n
is just a different way of talking about
the same thing
so now if you count the quantifier
complexity of this sentence
so I have unbounded for all and then a
bounded Y and the bounded X so this is
going to be a four hour Sigma B2
sentence
and for this reason it's provable in
t3pv
it's a t3pv can prove the Dual principle
it's an axiom of the field
so any questions so far
you don't hear effective signals here
you do not have effective Syntax for
your actions right
um
the way Define
true
facts
so that's going to make us make our own
probabilities stronger but you can also
consider weaker field is where the axons
are decided
probability this is
I was going to explain how the
relationship
let me just say that that's hierarchy
talks about basic axons and then some
form of induction
for some classic formulas
and if you just count the quantifier
complex of this induction sentences they
will be in some level of the height so
maybe s i 2 is in
two or three PV so
yeah definitely enough to do
something
yeah these are very strong fear is
because we take out true sentences yeah
okay so um
it seems that it's I uh girls it would
get like more actions and you'll be able
to prove more feelings but this is
currently openness
so the intuition is that this is the
case
thank you one reason is because we can
capture this question for instance with
respect to the two first periods we can
show the TF and P collapses to FP if you
know if t1pv proves the same field as
t250
okay so under assumptions there's a
hierarchy and the sphere is uh they get
stronger but showing the
unconditionalism
any questions so far
okay so finally let me mention this to
the APC one which I
alluded to before so this was introduced
by yahab it's a very beautiful work
and it's able to formalize a class of
probabilistic methods and randomize
algorithms so not every probabilistic
argument you can do in APC one but
there's a large class of them
and
it's an extension of this pv1 with this
dual weak physical principle sentences
for every function symbols
and
for the purpose of this talk
you can just think of abc1 as being t1pv
so these are our true Universal
sentences plus this scheme of this Axiom
scheme so for every function symbol we
add this dual principle for that
function
instead of formally defines the pc1
that's not the original definition it's
actually stronger than making survive
but that's going to be enough for us to
show improvability
and by the previous discussion because
by looking at the quantifier complex of
these axons
every Axiom of abc1 is containing t350
okay so everything can prove in apis one
you can also prove in t3pv
will be enough for us to get on
probability for a person
okay so I don't have much time but let
me talk tell you about the previous
paper so in 95 rasparov initiated this
study of complexity lower bounds in
boundary but it's metic and since then
has been like numerous papers both
inbounded arithmetic and in the setting
of prepositional uh in the propositional
setting uh studying the probability of
lower bounds
for yourself the most relevant papers uh
this one introduced by krycheck which
introduced one of the main techniques
and uh extension of this idea that
appear in a paper of p and more recently
in Peak and sentina where
uh they asked the investigated
improvability of lower bounds and most
importantly Peak and Santana they
established a non-conditional result
okay so let me tell you about this paper
in the next slide
so they consider a strong complexity
lower bounds uh separating NP from Conan
deterministic circuits
so we fix a
non-deterministic polytime machine em so
this is like any non-deterministic
polytime machine
and they consider a sentence stating the
following lower bound
that for every large enough n
and for every conon deterministic Circle
D of sub-exponential size
then this machine m and d they disagree
on uh one percent of the input strings
we feel this is a strong lower bound
because it's like a NP against sub
exponential size circuits and also in
the weak average case set
will you check out the sizes yeah so uh
I'm gonna explain this in more detail
later but this is like a log log
formalization so you can quantify of
entire Thrift tables to express the
sentence
and what they prove is that uh no matter
the machine that you face uh this lower
bound sentences is not provable in this
here t1pv and also in a fragment of this
uh yahadex here apcr
okay so they prove design conditional
results
and uh our main motivations in this
project
were to obtain results for stronger fear
is
and in particular to be able to show it
for APC one
and also trying to understand more
natural formalizations uh in the
following sense here
the way this is done is you fix the
machine outside the fury for every fixed
machine you postulate the lower Bound
for that machine
and this is done to reduce the
quantifier complexity of the sentence so
you can apply standard witnessing
techniques
interested in uh
formulations where you can in some sense
quantify over the machine inside the
sentence which would be like more
natural so you have a single sentence
that saves the lower bound instead of a
collection of sentences
um but this introduce another quantifier
in the sentence and it is high it's
harder to manipulate descendants of
higher Quantified complexity
these were the two motivations like to
get to Stronger feelings and to maybe
look at sentences that are a little bit
more natural in the way they state the
law about
okay so now let me uh just describe the
the results
we look at separations this strong form
of separations between pi I circuits and
sigma I circuits
so these are just the extensions to the
height level of the polynomial hierarchy
so for instance uh we will have a
sentence saying for every large enough
and there exists a pi three Circuit of
polycytes that is say one percent far
from every Sigma three Circuit of
sub-exponential size
and what do I mean by uh Pi I and sigma
I circuits
so these are just deterministic circuits
but we interpret the computation in the
sense of the polynomial hierarchy okay
so they have extra inputs and we have
like quantifiers for these inputs
but the way the sentence refers to these
objects these are just like numbers and
you inter when you talk about their
computations we need to use extra
quantifiers to describe
so uh more formally so we have uh lower
bound LBI sentence
that says for every n in log log so we
can manipulate Thrift tables in the
sentence so this is at the explanation
so for every n in log log that is some
Pi I uh Circuit of size S1
that is mildly average piece hard
against Sigma I circuits of size S2
that's the more General formulation of
the sentence
this is not like a fully formal sentence
but just wanted to give you a little bit
more details about how this is done
because of this log log
uh it means that your proves potential
proofs of the sentence they can
manipulate objects of bit length to the
n
and also if you are playing witnessing
the algorithms you extract from the
proof they are going to run in time to
today
yeah let me just say that because the
theory can manipulate objects of
exponential size if you show an
improvability result in this setting
it's a stronger result okay okay it
would be easier to prove them so you can
quantify over such larger objects
so in the top one you have one over and
far and on the bottom you have amobin
which is uh so how big is M1 just in the
yeah so uh
be the exact number so it would be like
2 to the end of our n streams
so you will you will actually yeah
that's the actual pronunciation
what questions
okay so the main result is that for
every fix it I every choice of
parameters for the size of the circuits
if you look at the pure TI that it
doesn't prove this lvi sentence okay so
this ldi sentence
again
is a staging that
that exists a pi I circuit that is
uh one over n far from every Sigma I
simply
off sub-exponential side
so yeah now we have like this single
sentence that also quantifies over this
uh
that's what I mean by
having like a higher quantifier
complexity of perhaps being a little bit
more natural
and uh as a Corollary
because uh p3pv contains APC one
we get apis one doesn't prove lb3
which is the lower bound sentence for
the third level of the polynomial
this is the informal result I mentioned
at the beginning
if if we're not quantify over so there's
these two issues
I'm not sure
okay so before I talk about the proof
any questions about the result of the
formalization could you state that
sentence again yes so uh for every large
enough hand that existed uh Pi I Circuit
of size n to the D
such that for every Sigma I Circuit of
size 2 to the N to the delta
there are just at the end of our end
streams where these two circuits are
different
it's a mild average case law about for
pi ISO fluids versus Sigma eye circles
one question
does this sentence
[Music]
so uh we use like a log work
organization so we can talk about
objects apply to the land
more questions
with respond input or something like
that
you said you have a mild in
approximation
the sentence consider is a one input
yeah so this will be our worst case all
about so right now we don't know how to
chamber of it
foreign
[Music]
so the proof is heavily based on the
street papers
they also extend their approach just by
taking Sentinel
and the main challenges for us is that
this theory is stronger and the
quantifier complex of the LBI sentence
is also larger
so here's the strategy so suppose this
field ipv could prove the LBI sentence
for this choice of parameters
and the key idea is that the proof of a
complex lower Bound in bounded
arithmetic in general
implies a corresponding complexity upper
bound
okay so from the lower bound proof that
can be formalized in these theories
we're going to get some kind of upper
bound some weak upper bound
and we're gonna argue that the lower
bound and the upper bound that we
extract from the proof they contradict
each other
now because this theories can only prove
through sentences
this contradiction at the end implies
that the original proof we assumed to
exist that's a contradiction it doesn't
exist
okay so the game is to get some upper
bound from the lower boundary
and I won't have time to explain the
proof in detail but I want to give you
an example
a simple setting where we can extract
upper bounds from lower bounds
so I call this uh constructive lower
bounds
so we'll be looking at the setting of NP
versus phonon deterministic circuits of
large enough polynomial size
and let's suppose like we fix a language
in NP and we fix a machine for this
language
and what do I mean by constructive lower
bound
there is a lower bound that also gives
to you a refuter
so this refilter for this language for
that machine given an input length m
uh so REM expects as input a common
deterministic Circuit of some large
enough poly size
and not only you're going to have this
lower bound but it's going to be a
constructive lower bound so this is a
filter given any candidate Circle it's
going to prove to you that it's wrong
it's going to give you like an input so
that's the guarantee
so that a filter gives you an input
where the machine aim on input length 0
m is different from this input Quantum
deterministic Circle
for the setting we care about we're
going to assume this refueler has a lot
of time so it runs in time it shoots at
the end
this is a object of size polyam we allow
the receiver to run in time to do that
okay so we have a lower bound that is
constructive in some sense also gives a
refutor so that's the Assumption that's
what we have and I would like to use
this with filter to extract a
non-trivial upper Bound for the language
l
okay and by non-trivio it's going to be
like a sub-exponential average case of
rebound
so that's the game that's the Assumption
we need to get some kind of approval
so any questions about the setting here
okay so we have this review
now we would like to approximate the
language
on length n
in time two to the end to the Delta for
in size to the N to the delta
and we want to use the filter
okay now this review runs in time sure
explanation in the input line
so if we're trying to achieve this we
better use or run this review on smaller
input lens okay so that's the first
thing we're going to do we'll be
focusing on how to use this review or
input length into the delta
okay while we're trying to compute the
original language on inputs of lymph n
so to do that we're going to encode the
original computation on input length as
a collection of quantum deterministic
circuits in a very simple way
so we're going to partition the input
into two blocks one is the large size n
minus n Delta and the order is the input
just n to the delta
we're going to consider a collection of
circuits indexed by the prefix or
possible prefixes
and the input is just the Y of size n to
the Delta and we construct this
collection
uh just by taking the complement of the
original non-deterministic machine
okay so there's no deterministic machine
we can talk about this cone on
deterministic circuit
that gets an input of length into the
delta
okay so we have this collection of
circuits one for each possible prefix
that computes according to the negation
of M of M
this is a collection of Conor
deterministic circuits of small input
length
and we can consider the computation of
the filter on each one of the circuits
okay now
we have a large collection of circuits
and each one has input length into the
delta
very few that will always find a counter
example
so there must be a counter example
string that occurs more often than the
others
just a simple fact
so if you run the filter on every
possible prefix there's going to be some
y star
that is produced with probably at least
two diminas into the delta
we're gonna store this y-star
non-uniformly and the proof now we want
to construct an upper Bound for the
original language and input software
yeah I'm going to start this y star
and we're going to compute in the
following way so we're giving an input
of length n to the original machine
we're going to break into two blocks
similar to what we did before in the
construction
and moreover
it's going to be useful in the proof to
assume that in the second part of the
input is exactly y star
so in this Construction
we're trying to do it on input Limbs and
if this second block is not y star
you're just going to Output random bit
and this is not going to hurt us too
much because this is often into the
delta we're hoping to get some kind of
non-trivical correlation we're losing
something here but
don't sugar probability we're going to
see why starting this part of the input
okay and now we're Computing the
following way
so just stay with me it's going to make
sense in a minute
so we take X we partition into two parts
we construct the circuit with the prefix
w
Ander a filter if we don't get y star we
again output a random bit
I'm not losing too much here in terms of
average case of a bound because we know
that y star happens with non-trivial
probabilities
but if we do get y star
then from the guarantee of the refilter
we know that the computation of inputs
of length into the Delta on y star
this disagrees with this Quantum
deterministic circuit on y star
this from the probability of the review
and from the construction this is just
the negation of M of n when we put
together the prefix in y star
so we derived this in this case
now this part here only depends on my
star
so this is a fixed bit that you can also
hard code in your circuit
so what happens is that you have learned
this value here
when these conditions are met you know
that the negation of M of n on the input
string you care about
you can recover it from this hard code a
bit
okay so just putting this together
this will allow us to construct a
circuit where you achieve a correlation
that is not trivial of order two to the
miners n to the delta
and the running time the complexity is
the complex of running this refilter
remember it takes exponential time but
we're running it on circuits of input
length into the algorithm
get a circle of size to the end to the
Delta as well
because it's a very simple construction
and it shows how to get a non-trivial
upper bound
from a constructive lower bound when you
have a review
okay that that's that's the entire
construction for this toy example maybe
it was a bit too fast but if you check
these lights again everything is
so I guess uh how much time
so maybe you can take questions then
questions about this Construction
management
uh
this argument only gives this can
actually have a different argument that
gives you a more space
but unfortunately the argument doesn't
extend to the proof we actually need
so this is closer
applications
um
it is the fact that you like having this
kind of compression right so you're
getting to enter the Delta there's this
more common string whatever that happens
you learn the value of the computation
and when it does then you can check when
it happens you just output a random bit
so the review that is finding a mistake
the fact that is a mistake kind of tells
you what's the correct output of this
definition
right I know something is a mistake and
I know the value of the invitation on
the point
so that's almost clear but let's make a
description of the group right uh yeah
thank you
more questions
okay so now let's move on to the actual
proof
so uh I'm gonna show tip doesn't prove
this lower bound sentences for the ice
level of the hierarchy
and by contradiction uh we suppose this
is doable so we have a proof
and the first step is just the trigger
step that if you can prove an average K
is lower bound then connect can also
prove a worst case lower bound
okay so we no longer need this number of
points is the worst case sentence that
just tells you that there's one mistake
it's a trivial step
from the proof of average case law bound
to get a proof of a worst case overbound
now the second step is this vast
generalization of the Twilight sample
where from the proof of a lower Bound in
the fury
we're going to extract an upper bound
okay
um
so we're actually going to show that for
every poly size Pi eye silk rate
that's going to be uh not too large uh
circuit with Sigma Pi minus 1 Oracle
Gates
that approximates the initial circuit e
in some non-trivial way
so this is slightly different from the
toy example I gave you before because
there I approximated this original
language uh L of the machine here
here you're actually approximating every
Pi I said not just the single one
and this is used in the group so for
every Pi I circuit we're going to get a
non-trivial approximation
now if you apply a harness amplification
for the polynomial hierarchy in its
constructive way
so if everything in pi I have has a
non-trivial approximation then
everything in pi I we actually you'll be
able to compute 1 1 minus one over
infractions
this allows us to move from the
non-trivial correlation to like 99
Vision this is done outside the field
finally
because this field can only prove
through statements this is going to be a
contradiction so we have just proved how
to non-trivially approximate every Pi I
circuit
but the sentence states that there
exists a pi I circuit that is hard on
average
it's a contradiction
that's that's the overview of the proof
and the main step is to extend this toy
example to the mainland how often
approving The View I get a non-trivial
upper bound
so let me just compare the the two cases
so in the toy example
we had this goal of showing a
non-trivial upper bound
the algorithmic information was that we
had better filter for the lower bound
okay so we have more than the lower
bound we have this algorithm defines a
mistake
and we use this algorithm
with a collection of circuits or at
least the proof we think of running it
on like a collection of circuits so we
we had to carefully pick this collection
to make use of the algorithmic
information
that was the toy example
now in the mainland we are also
interested in getting a non-trivial
operable
but what's going to change is that we
won't have a filter
so from the proof in the theory we gonna
have what is called a winning strategy
in a certain game
and in this game there is a player that
is trying to construct a hard circuit pi
and there's another player default
player that is trying to show actually
there is a smaller Sigma I circuit for
that construction so there's two players
they they have proposing goals
and from this witnessing theorem for
games we're gonna have some kind we're
gonna extract from the proof some kind
of winning strategy for the existential
player that is trying to construct a
hard function
so this winning strategy in some sense
beating every candidate's mother simply
so this witness this winning strategy is
playing the role of the future here
it's a more complicated uh collection of
algorithms than just having in the
future
and we need to play this game yeah just
say that
to talk more about the team but it will
say at least the difference is that this
game and this particle house
yeah so here we have the one shot the
filter like give him a zip with a paint
you a mistake
here they're going to have
let's play the game several rounds you
also have a larger number of quantifiers
and so we have things like significantly
more complicated
and what you need to do is
while here I had to pick the input for
the filter
here I need to pick the strategies of
the federal player
that I'm going to defeat
so I need to carefully chose this for
our players and how I'm going to use
that to construct another bouncer
and
let me just say that the way this is
done like we don't have this simple
construction we you need to use ideas
from severeign
also appears in the previous papers
is there
in this games the existential player can
change the heart Circle
so the the existence of a hardship is
part of the sentence and as you play it
again you can also change the candidate
currency
so let's introduce some additional
difficulties
okay so that's all I have to say about
the proof let me mention now some uh
so we have established a number of a bit
of uh strong lower bound
and you can think of it as maybe
evidence that the overground could be
true okay so like how it was explained
you show on province in a very strong
field perhaps the opposite statements
I think maybe for us to always keep in
mind you know all these lower bounds and
perhaps it's very strong ones it could
potentially be found
and that's a reason for the result to be
like they send it to be improved
I don't know how many people will
consider this original possibility I
would like to mention just to be fair on
like how to interpretation
the second question is really divided by
so can we show them probably the NBC one
for a lower bound sentence we talked
about the second language
this would be interesting perhaps it's
doable we haven't spent much time
and finally uh to show the improvability
of worst case loadouts this would be
very interesting
you kind of don't have a technique
all right thank you
regarding the first first bullet I think
if you replace put the Android data back
to the end like it's actually that long
it's true right so MP is actually in two
to the end maybe to the O and side
current code code and circuits
who knows
yeah there's a trivia
okay any containing with any bits of
advice it's simple but I mean it's an
interesting idea
what question
okay since we are running behind the
schedule Let's uh leave the questions
after the talks and thank you again
[Applause]